tilda swinton is an actor like no other
with wide-ranging roles in films like
doctor strange and suspiria
it may have been a while since winton's
last big movie but that doesn't mean she
hasn't been busy
here's why you may not have seen very
much of swinton lately
when swinton first began her acting
career she moved to london to work with
the royal shakespeare company
however she moved back to her childhood
home of scotland once she had grown
tired of the city life
a small town homebody at heart she has
made a comfortable life for herself and
her family in the scottish highlands
as she said in an interview for esquire
i mean i've even lost the way of living
in a city
if i had to live in a city again it
would take me a long time
you have to train up to live in a city
today swinton says that she rarely
visits london anymore and feels that she
is out of touch with the industry there
although she does occasionally think
about moving back to a city
she has no plans to do so in the near
future
swinton has fans all around the world
but she couldn't tell you what they're
saying about her online
thanks to her decision to stay off
social media entirely
the actor considers herself a quote
complete luddite
telling vogue i have no presence on
social media
absolutely none i just have other things
to do
i know what's going on it's like there's
a forest on fire somewhere down the end
of the garden
but i'm concentrating on the roses while
swinton's fans would probably
love to see her on twitter or instagram
it's unlikely she'll be creating an
account anytime soon
application tonight i'm sorry despite
her bulky resume
swinton insists that she is not an
ambitious person saying
i've never had any ambition as an artist
that may sound crazy and transgressive
but it's a fact in fact swinton has
admitted that she does not even think of
herself as a traditional actress
even though she's been acting for over
30 years while she will certainly accept
the opportunity to appear in a
blockbuster franchise when the chance
comes around
she isn't specifically seeking out these
roles and swinton doesn't go to
auditions anymore either
she's accomplished enough that directors
come to her overall she will always put
passion over potential profits
for swinton the director she's working
with is often more important than the
film itself
she has worked at least three times each
with directors wes anderson
jim jarmisch and luca guadagnino in the
early years of her career she worked
closely with director derek jarman
on several more experimental films which
taught her that supportive relationships
with directors who shared her vision
were the key to artistic fulfillment in
an interview swinton told the
independent
we are used to actors moving from
project to project in a slightly
detached
way or that they are looking over their
shoulder for a more interesting project
or more money
but that is not how i approach it i need
to work with people that i can trust
i always choose the people first swinton
is far more likely to wait for an
intriguing
role with the right director even if it
means passing up roles that other actors
might have jumped at
swinton knows that a great film can take
time which is why she's willing to spend
several years patiently working to give
a single project the attention
it deserves swinton states that this
kind of focused
long-term attention makes her process
unique allowing her to personally
develop her roles alongside her
directors and writers
she revealed to variety most people
don't develop work the way i
customarily do they'll wait for someone
to place them into their universe with
proper craftspeople
whereas i spend most of my time sitting
around my kitchen table with friends
chewing on ideas and building things
that take years
swinton spent five years working on the
film orlando with director sally potter
and she dedicated quote seven or eight
years to
only lovers left alive she even spent as
many as 11 years committed to her role
in
i am love learning both russian and
italian to make her character seem as
realistic as possible
swinton's name rarely makes it into the
tabloids and even when it does
she isn't very interested in joining in
the conversation rarely feeling the need
to clarify details about her
personal and romantic life with the
press in fact it often takes her a while
to hear through the grapevine if there
is a rumor spreading about her in the
first place
she joked i'm playful at heart and myth
making is always fun
for instance when swinton began dating
artist sandro copp
the press speculated that she had first
gotten together with cop during her
relationship with her previous partner
of 14 years
playwright john byrne the gossip spread
for years before swinton realized what
was being said and had to come forward
to state that it was nothing but a rumor
i mean this is really inappropriate
if swinton hasn't been filming
blockbusters what has she been working
on
while fans of swinton might have caught
her latest big name projects
some of her recent work has flown under
the radar in 2020 she lent her voice to
the late composer johann johansson for
his experimental film
last and first men the movie explores a
futuristic society in which evolved
humans face potential extinction
and surreal monuments beam out messages
into the universe
swinton also worked on several short
films in 2020
she narrated story and the writer which
explored a man's efforts to write the
perfect screenplay
in addition she appeared in pedro
almodovars the human voice
in which she played a woman who notes
the passing of time while she waits for
her ex-lover to come and pick up his
suitcases
while the short was not widely viewed it
did receive some glowing reviews
as critic ryan rojas wrote in a review
for cinemasy
tilda swinton commands every second of
the small screen in pedro almodovar's
beautifully staged and winkingly meta
new short film in august 2020
the personal history of david
copperfield was released
armando yanuchi's comedic drama adapted
charles dickens classic story for the
modern age
starring dev patel as the title
character swinton portrayed betsy
trotwood
david copperfield's eccentric great aunt
who takes him in
and ends up financing his dream of
becoming an author
oh my lawn unbox your ears
off you go this is a donkey free zone
move it
although critics held a generally
positive opinion of the film
that didn't prevent it from being a flop
at the box office
the timing of its release certainly
didn't help as the film arrived in
theaters in the midst of the covid19
pandemic
once a majority of movie theaters had
temporarily closed down for safety
reasons
the pandemic disrupted the production
schedule for countless movies and tv
shows
many directors had to postpone shooting
for months on end
leaving lots of release dates in limbo
while some studios have chosen to
release their new films through
streaming services
others have decided simply to delay
their releases
meaning audiences will have to wait a
little while longer to see them
that was the case for swinton's highly
anticipated movie the french dispatch
the wes anderson flick was originally
slated for a july 2020 release
likely at the cannes film festival
however the festival was cancelled
because of the coven 19 pandemic
and the tentative release date was
pushed to october 2020
which was again postponed until 2021
swinton also has experience behind the
camera she's currently working on a
documentary about progressive education
systems around the world
swinton has been interested in creating
schools that encourage students to reach
their full potential for years
having co-founded the drumduin upper
school in scotland where her own
children attended
the school does not require students to
take tests or even sit at desks most of
the time
so it's likely that her documentary will
focus on unorthodox approaches to
education
this won't be swinton's first time
directing in 2008 she was one of several
directors for the documentary
the new ten commandments which explores
human rights in scotland
and in 2016 she collaborated with
several other directors for the film
the seasons in quincy four portraits of
john berger
a tribute to the respected novelist
while it might seem like swinton has
been laying low
she has been as busy as ever having been
working on several upcoming projects for
some time
first up is her film the souvenir part
two
a sequel to her 2019 film the souvenir
in which she stars alongside her
daughter
honor swinton byrne her movie the
eternal daughter is also anticipated to
release in 2021
multiple upcoming swinton films have yet
to gain official release dates
but fans can expect to see her in films
such as the fantasy epic
3000 years of longing and the drama
memoria
she's also going to be voicing the fairy
with turquoise hair
and guillermo del toro's dark adaptation
of the classic story
pinocchio check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one